that's what their videos well I am next
to Duchess of Sussex Megan Markel is
going vogue folks she's making fashion
history she's the first guest editor of
the September issue of British Vogue in
the magazines 103 year history the
issues called forces for change and it
features candid a candid conversation
between the Duchess and Michelle Obama
former first lady it also has a little
conversation between Prince Harry and
famed anthropologist dr. Jane Goodall
you know this was something that Megan
Markel says she really wanted to focus
on she wanted to make sure that women
from a wide range of backgrounds had
that you know were trailblazing and and
and and you know everyone from Jane
Fonda Salma Hayek Lauren Cox Yara
Shahidi to prime minister of New Zealand
for for her age with the with you know
its forces have changed at passing the
gun the gun laws there - climate change
activists credit therm Berg I mean and a
mirror to force readers to look at
themselves and be a force of change
that's wonderful yeah a mirror